mond mercherb le vrai dialogue s'engage
Val cardestin bientôt en Bretagne la
Maré noire sur plus de 100 km de plage
les premiers résultats de l'Institut de
roscov la mort voulue après le rapport
kayav un débat qui nous concerne tous
plie vent et neige dans de nombreuses
régions il faut remonter loin dans le
temps pour trouver un mois d'avril aussi
froid
Madame Mademoiselle Monsieur bonsoir une
loi peut-elle organiser la mort d'un
être humain depuis hier après-midi
depuis que le sénateur kayavet a déposé
son projet de loi visant à la
légalisation sinon de l'euthanasie au
moins d'un certain droit à la mort la
controverse s'est ouverte l'euthanasie
vous le savez c'est le sujet tabou c'est
le débat qui oppose certains malades
incurables à leur médecins qui oppose
les médecins entre eux et qui est
condamné par 20 siècles de religion
chrétienne hier après-midi le sénateur
kayav a donc relancé le débat un débat
qui occupera la plus grande part de
notre journal nous y reviendrons après
avoir vu le reste de l'actualité mais
tout de suite et pour que les choses
soient bien claires je vous propose de
prendre connaissance dans le détail de
la proposition du sénateur du lotte et
Garon voici cette proposition de loi
tout majeur ou mineur émancipé saint
d'esprit a la faculté de déclarer sa
volonté qu'aucun moyen médical ou
chirurgical autre que ceux destiné à
calmer sa souffrance ne soit utilisé
pour prolonger artificiellement sa vie
s'il est atteint d'une affection
accidentelle ou pathologique
incurable dans une dizaine de minutes
donc nous entamerons cette première
réflexion sur le droit à la
mort Monsieur M maire est resté durant
2h de ce matin atteinte dans le bureau
de Monsieur raymondb à l'Hôtel Matignon
une discussion fort longue donc et qui
selon les termes employés à l'Hôtel
Matignon s'est déroulé dans un bon
climat pour les services du Premier
ministre la discussion a plus progresser
sur un certain nombre de sujets
monsieurmontmaire lui-même en sortant de
cette entrevue a estimé que le premier
ministre avait avancé un certain nombre
de suggestions fort intéressantes sur
des thèmes auxquels la CFDT tient
beaucoup la discussion que nous avons eu
a été véritablement je crois qu'on peut
dire
approfondi le Premier ministre a avancé
un certain nombre de suggestions de
procédure que nous avons jugé
positive sur un certain nombre de thèmes
qui nous tiennent particulièrement à
cœur qu'il s'agisse des bas salaires et
du SMIC de
l'emploi de toutes les catégories mais
aussi des jeunes de la réduction de la
durée du travail
des conditions de
travail et des droits syndicaux
avez-vous trouvé un changement de ton
dans l'attitude du Premier ministre il
est évident qu'il y avait une assez
grande différence entre la rencontre que
nous avions eu en septembre 76 lors de
l'installation du premier gouvernement
bar et la rencontre d'aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui nous
croyons enfin nous avons constaté une
entrée dans la discussion réelle du
Premier ministre
et une attitude de recherche de
procédurees
accepable qui nous le disons très
clairement dénote dans le bon sens avec
l'attitude qui avait été la sienne il y
a 18
mois monsieur raymondbard dans les 15
prochains jours recevra les autres
dirigeants syndicaux la CGT et la CGC et
patronau le CNPF et les PM le Conseil
des ministres du 26 avril mettra un
point
définitif le plan social du gouvernement
vous l'avez entendu l'un des grands
problèmes pour les syndicats et pour la
CFDT notamment c'est celui des bas
salaires et du SMIC pendant la campagne
électorale beaucoup de chiffres avaient
été avancés je vous propose de faire le
point en ce domaine pendant la campagne
électorale augmentation des bas salaires
arimé avec progression du SMIC les
débats ont tourné autour de la
proposition faite par les Parti de
Gauche de porter le SMIC à 2400 francs
par mois dans la majorité le débat est
lancé par Jean-Jacques servant Schreiber
qui affirme qu'un SMIC à 2400 francs
était possible dès
1979 pour Michel patovski le SMIC doit
augmenter plus vite que les autres
salaires sa progression en pouvoir
d'achat pourrait atteindre dit-il 8 à 10
% par an pour Jacques Chirac
augmentation des bass salaires doit
s'accompagner d'une diminution des
charges des entreprises et pour le
Premier ministre 2400 francs par mois
c'est possible mais dans le courant de
la législat le problème essentiel et
pour le Premier ministre d'augmenter les
bas salaires plus vite que les autres
c'est la même question qui reste posée
mais ce qu'il y a de nouveau semble-t-il
c'est qu'on cherche actuellement des
solutions pour faire progresser ces bass
salaires qui soient plus original qu'une
augmentation mécanique du SMIC le
gouvernement veut éviter de faire bouger
l'ensemble des salaires afin de ne pas
augmenter le prix des produits français
il est possible que les discussions de
Matignon débouchent sur des solutions
originales que discuterons su syndicat
et
patronat conséquence de la formation du
gouvernement de Monsieur Raymond bar la
délégation à l'aménagement du territoire
et à l'action régionale sera placé
désormais sous l'autorité directe du
premier ministre dans le gouvernement
précédent la DATAR dépendait du
ministère de l'équipement dans la
conjoncture actuelle Monsieur Raymond
bar juge que les problèmes de l'emploi
et de mise en valeur des atouts
économiques des régions seront mieux
servis par le rattachement de la DATAR
au service de l'hôtel matigan dans le
domaine politique Monsieur Jean
enenstein publ aujourd'hui dans dans le
monde le dernier des trois articles qu'
a consacré au problèmes du Parti
communiste français après les élections
dans cet article le directeur adjoint du
Centre d'études et de recherche marxiste
demande que justice soit rendue aux
exclus du parti communiste pourquoi
avoir exclu Roger garudi demande-il en
souhaitant également que la direction du
Parti communiste français reconnaisse
ses torts et ses fautes qui ont entraîné
en 1952 l'exclusion de mieur Charles
Tillon et André Marti enfin Jean
eininstein évoque le centralisme
démocratique à ses yeux le parti ne doit
pas se contenter d'un débat trop rapide
amorcé par une prise de position
télévisée la télé central écrit-il ne
doit pas remplacer le Comité central ce
matin l'humanité semble d'ailleurs faire
un pas en direction des intellectuels du
parti le problème n'est pas de savoir où
ils écrivent déclare en substance René
andriilleux l'important c'est le contenu
de leur
discours en vacances à Courchevel
monsieur Valérie giscardestin a évoqué
cet après-midi la pollution causée par
les pétroles le chef de l'État a annoncé
que d'ici 3 mois les U pays européens
allaient prendre toutes les mesures
préventives pour éviter la pollution le
président de la République a aussi
annoncé qu'il se rendrait prochainement
avec sa famille en Bretagne dans la
région polluée par l'amoko Cadiz la mer
est d'ailleurs mauvaise aujourd'hui en
Bretagne et la Maré noire a atteint les
côtes déjà victimes des deux précédentes
catastrophes cell de l'olympicque
bravery en janvier 76 et du Bolen en
octobre de la même année mais au-delà de
cette pollution visible et visible
certainement encore bien longtemps il y
a autre chose laamoko cadise en
déversant à quelques centaines de mètres
de porsal 200000 tonnes de pétrole a
littéralement empoisonné une partie de
l'Atlantique et de la Manche une
pollution sournoise qui tue certes les
oiseaux mais aussi les poissons et tous
les micro-organismes 200000 tonnes de
pétrole cela veut peut-être dire 5 ou 10
années de désert
marin l'émotion l'amertume sont-elle que
la colère en est étouffée comment la mer
peut-elle être aussi si injuste
vis-à-vis de la Bretagne depuis des
semaines on a tant et tant travaillé que
cette plage que vous voyez comme
d'ailleurs la plupart de Cell qui avaiit
été touché cette plage avait fini par
retrouver une allure convenable dire
qu'il va falloir recommencer c'est dur
cette mer ici on l'aime mais depuis hier
les Bretons sont encore une fois des
amants bafoués ce pétrolier qui remplace
camion citne et wagons pour l'évacuation
des déchets mazoutés va encore et là
servir c'est le même qui s'est échoué ce
matin en cornoy en attendant un nouveau
coup du sort on scha a étudié les
conséquences du déversement de 230000
tonnes de mazout dans la Manche une mer
dans la mer en surface en bordure du
litoral on ne voit presque plus de trac
seul les rochers sont encore fortement
marqués ce matin pourtant le bateau du
centre biologique de roskov est encore
sorti sa mission faire des prélèvements
bien sûr et étudier les conséquences de
la pollution sur la faune et sur la
flore ainsi d'ailleurs que l'Institut
des pêches
maritimes il semble clair que notre
notamment dans les sédiments fins
surtout dans les sédiments fins il y a
un piégeage du maoute au fond ça on a
l'impression quand on vient ici après 3
semaines que finalement il y a pas grand
chose on voit plus
rien mais évidemment les gens qui
viennent maintenant ne pe pas ne peuvent
pas se rendre compte de l'inondation
sauvage qui a eu le 21 mars suroscof ça
n'est c'est plus du tout la même chose
maintenant la surface paraît je dirais
presque vide mais en profondeur vous
pouvez constater sur ces bassines on le
voit on voit les irrisations à surface
il y a une pénétration dans les
sédiments dans dans la baie de morl
le mazoute déposé sur les sédiments
voilà le danger à long terme ces
sédiments du sable fin et vaseux peu
remués par les courants sont en fait une
véritable nurserie c'est là que la faune
se reproduit naî et grandit circonstance
aggravante l'absence de fort courant
fait que le pétrole peut rester là
longtemps et mettre des années avant de
se dégrader dans l'immédiat 50 % des
huîtres des quatre grands secteur de
production touché sont mortes les autres
sont impropres à la consommation elles
ont un goût étrange de pavillon de
complaisance quant au crustacés et au
poissons ces lieux par exemple pris ce
matin à 5000 de l'épave de la mokocadis
ils sont dans le même cas ils ont
également le gû de Mazou notion
optimiste toutefois les constatations
des chercheurs de l'Institut des pêche
maritime permettent de penser qu'à court
terme ces animaux contaminés pourraient
redevenir
comestibles à peu près tous les tous les
animaux ont le pouvoir de de
s'autoépurer en quelque sorte euh reste
à savoir en combien de temps et ça c'est
c'est là le le problème ça prendra très
vraisemblablement plusieurs mois mais
c'est pas un vu que vous formulez c'est
c'est une certitude c'est une certitude
c'est une certitude oui ça a été ça a
été vu lors de de du naufrage du Bolen
des crabes qui avaient été maoutés ont
été conservés au laboratoire et se sont
autoépurés au bout de quelques mois en
attendant si sur beaucoup de points
leurs avis divergent il en est un au
moins sur lequel les scientifiques sont
d'accord
il faudra 3 ou 4 ans avant de pouvoir
faire de cette catastrophe un bilan
biologique
convenable ce document que vous
découvrez derrière moi c'est une affiche
officielle qui a été placardée ces
jour-ci sur tous les murs de Canton et
qui révèle qu'en Chine aussi on condamne
à mort les dissidents politiques en
l'occurrence c'est un enseignant de 45
ans qui a été condamné pour avoir
distribué une brochure
antigouvernementale au Proche Orient
après 5 jours de combat dans la banlieue
de Beyrouth l'accord de cesser le feu
conclu hier entre les forces
conservatrices et les progressistes de
la force armée arabe de dissuasion
semble être respecté de part et d'autrre
aujourd'hui au Sud Liban la seconde
phase du retrait israélien a commencé
comme prévu et elle a commencé il y a
quelques heures les Israéliens continue
toutefois à tenir un certain nombre de
positions stratégiques sur le secteur
occidental monsieur George segéi a écrit
au Premier ministre monsieur Bergeron en
a parlé directement avec Monsieur
Raymond bar Daniel conbandit veut
revenir en France pour l'instant le
gouvernement n'a pas fait connaître sa
décision on ne sait donc pas si l'ordre
d'expulsion signé en 1968 à l'encontre
de celui que l'on appelait alors Dani le
rouge sera ou non rapporté daniel
conbandit vit en Allemagne depuis 10 ans
qu'est-il devenu Michel Meyer a mené
l'enquête Francfort cette maison très
colorée détonne dans son quartier
résidentiel depuis des années elle est
occupée par un groupe de protestation
contre les constructeurs qui veulent la
détruire afin d'en libérer le terrain
c'est ici que vit Daniel conbandit
depuis plusieurs années il est
corresponsable d'une librairie
spécialisée dans la littérature de
GA avant ses activités de libraire
conbandit s'est longtemps occupé
d'enfant à la garderie étudiante de
l'Université de
Francfort depuis l'Allemagne il suit
avec une extrême attention les
interventions qui viennent d'avoir lieu
à son sujet en France il ne désespère
pas pouvoir retourner à Paris 10 ans
après mes
68 la France c'est la moitié de ma vie
j'ai vécu les 2 tiers de ma vie en
France j'ai des tas d'amis j'ai mon
frère qui existe en France qui vit en
France donc je veux rentrer en France je
veux revoir les gens que j'aime beaucoup
je veux pouvoir voyager comme un pot de
yaourt et une Volkswagen c'est-à-dire
l'Europe est ouverte à tout le monde
pourquoi elle serait pas ouverte à tous
les êtres humains donc pourquoi l'Europe
ne serait pas ouverte à moi donc de
faire l'aller-retour France Allemagne
comme tout le monde moi je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec tous ceux qui
demandent la levée de mon interdiction
il y a pas que Monsieur seggi par
exemple je peux dire aujourd'hui que
Monsieur Raymond Aaron a écrit une
lettre à Monsieur au à la présidence
demandant aussi la levée de mon
interdiction de séjour disant d'ailleurs
que je n'étais pas dangereux et qui
trouvait euh mon interdiction de séjour
donc assez ridicule moi je ne le
contredis pas je ne suis pas dangereux
là n'est vraiment pas mon problème
précisément euh conb dit dit Daniel
conbendit Dani le rouge c'est une
légende en France déjà c'est une sorte
de mythe il faut bien le dire
révolutionnaire dangereux la réalité
c'est quoi aujourd'hui écoutez la
réalité c'est beaucoup de choses mais en
ce qui concerne mon interdiction de
séjour j'avoue franchement que je ne
comprends pas et je crois qu'il n'y a
que les nostalgiques de la répression
qui peuvent eux comprendre pourquoi en
fin de compte l'interdiction de jour
pèse toujours sur moi si y a des
problèmes on verra mais ce que je
comprends pas c'est 10 ans après
pourquoi ne pas lever C interdiction
d'autant plus que ça m'embête beaucoup
dans le sens que ça m'oblige à perpétuer
un mythe qui peut-être s'atténuerait
tout de suite s'il y avait pas cette
interdiction donc si le mythe fait
tellement peur un des moyens de détruire
le mythe c'est de lever l'interdiction
de séjour et c'est pour ça que
vraiment d'un niveau politique et d'un
niveau humain je ne comprends vraiment
pas pourquoi cette lition de séjour pèse
toujours sur moi très rapidement
politiquement où en êtes-vous je suis
politiquement toujours là d'où je suis
parti en 68 je suis quelque part
ailleurs politiquement ça c'est assz
long à décrire je crois pas que je peux
faire ça en 2
minutes l'un des plus célèbres casinos
de Nice le Palais de la Méditerranée
vient de déposer son bilan à l'origine
la guerre sourde entre Jean-Dominique
Fratoni PDG du brle un casino concurrent
et qui possède 50 % des actions du
Palais de la Méditerranée et l'ex PDG
René lerou dont le groupe était
majoritaire jusqu'à l'été
dernier le Palais de la Méditerranée est
occupé depuis cet après-midi par ses 383
employés à la suite de la décision du
conseil d'administration de déposer son
bilan et aussi afin d'éviter la rupture
du dialogue avec la direction et la
fermeture du casino depuis que
Jean-Dominique Fratoni PDG du casino du
Roule s'était assuré le contrôle de
l'établissement la situation du Palais
de la Méditerranée n'avait cessé de se
dégrader l'ex PDG du Palais de la
Méditerranée madame lerou propriétaire
de 50 % des actions considère comme
arbitraire et non fondée cette décision
du dépô de bilan de la nouvelle gestion
a été une politique d'asphyxie d'où le
résultat que nous
connaissons de son côté le groupe
Fratoni accuse madame lerou d'être
l'artisan de cette mauvaise gestion
décidément les casinos nissois sont bien
malades neuf groupiers du casino du
Roule dirigé par Jean-Dominique Fratoni
auraiit été écroué à la suite d'une
affaire de détournement et de trucage
des
jeux voilà pour ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui en France et dans le monde
l'homme a-t-il le droit de choisir
l'heure de sa mort en commençant ce
journal nous vous avons montré le texte
d'une proposition de loi signée de
Monsieur Henri cayavet le sénateur du
Lot etgaron monsieur kayavet ne propose
pas l'euthanasie il dénonce avant tout
l'acharnement de certains médecins qui
même lorsque tout est perdu et
nonobstant la souffrance des malades
mettent tout en œuvre pour repousser la
mort même si ce qui subsiste n'est plus
tout à fait la vie mais peut-on
réellement parler du droit à la mort
lorsque l'on n'a pas été soi-même
confronté à la maladie vous savez à
cette longue et cruelle maladie par
exemple dont parle les ferp de deuil
pour parler de la mort parfois pour Lapp
de ses vœux il faut avoir cogné à sa
porte ou avoir vu l'un de ses proches
s'enfoncer dans l'enfer pour ce dossier
je vous propose d'écouter donc le
témoignage de Madame stanu son frère est
entré en janvier 1977 à l'hôpital Claude
Bernard ensuite il en connaîtra CQ
autres il décédera le 26 juin 77 mais
entre Janvier et join le frère de Madame
stanu aura subi cinq opérations il sera
resté 70 jours en réanimation intense il
avait 56 ans écouter sa
sœur j'ai vu mon frère dans un état j'ai
dit va mourir
mais j'ai dit pi qu'il souffre
pas et puis je suis rentrée chez moi
parce que je ne pouvais rien faire
d'autre mais il me comprenait il me
parlait et comme on l'avait remis en
salle seul au 5e étage
isolé avec naturellement l'appareil pour
que l'infirmière entende en cas d'arrêt
cardiaque je ne sais pas pourquoi je je
conservais espoir encore jusqu'à ce
moment-là que vous
disait-il il pouvait à peine parler à ce
moment-là il était pas intubé il avait
fait très peu de Ré hein
et je lui ai dit tu vois je pense que
cette fois c'est terminé il m'a fait
deux fois arrête je écoute cette fois-ci
ça va
s'arranger et tu verras tu
sortiras il m'a dit
non puis je suis rentrée chez moi puis à
3h du matin je crois le téléphone a
sonné on me dit Madame votre frère est
dans le coma mon mari s'habille en
vitesse m'amène en
voiture c'était une docteuresse une
réanimatrice je vais en RA directement
elle me laisse pas rentrer je lui dis
écoutez je vous en prie arrêtez c'est
plus la peine d'insister laissez tomber
je vous en suppli laissz elle m'a dit
non madame sans ça j'aurais pas de
raison d'être vous avez demandé à ce que
l'on abrge les souffrances je dis qu'on
arrête tout qu'on le laisse mourir je
dis arrêtez deux fois c'est suffisant
deux opérations à cœur ouvert arrêtez il
a fait un Comat maintenant il aura des
lésions cérébrales laissez-le mourir je
vous en supplie je vous supplie de
laisser laissez-le il n'a rien il n'a
pas de famille il n'a rien il a rien sur
terre et là que
moi rien à faire et oui rien à faire
l'euthanasie n'existe pas en France les
médecins dans la majorité ils sont
d'ailleurs hostil le Conseil de l'Ordre
s'oppose en tout cas à toute
légalisation de l'euthanasie mais alors
fautil laisser souffrir les malades
au-delà du supportable et bien c'est le
seul cas répond le professeur
Schwarzenberg où le médecin peut faire
en conscience quelque chose on dispose
de médicaments injectables par voie
veineuse ou qui peuvent permettre de
faire dormir un malade vous êtes allé
jusque
là faut que je vous réponde honnêtement
oui vous avez écrit dans votre livre je
crois je mets les pilules sur la table
de nuit non j'ai pas non ça c'est une
une erreurs d'inscription j'ai raconté
qu'un médecin américain faisait ça
personnellement ça m'est jamais arrivé
quand il m'est
arrivé d'aider un malade à dormir parce
qu'on peut pas dire qu'on est que quiil
que ce soit à mourir on meurt toujours
seul puis nous on reste alors quand on
nide pas quelqu'un quand on aide
quelqu'un sans l'accompagner c'est pas
honnête il m'est toujours arrivé quand
j'ai quand je faisais cet acte de le
faire personnellement et de ne pas le
laisser le malade lui-même avaler ses
pilules avec son verre d'eau dans la
solitude d'une chambre d'hôpital ce qui
me paraît horrible est-ce que cette
décision appartient vraiment au seul
médecin est-ce que il faudra peut-être
pas consulter les proches du
malades si bien sûr mais il arrive que
les proches vous disent ah ça suffit
docteur il y a des gens qui ont fait le
voyage par exemple ça m'est arrivé
récemment il a une dame qui est venue
d'Amérique pour voir sa sœur qui
n'allait pas bien et qui pensait que ça
allait se terminer en 4 jours et qui m'a
dit je suis venu pour ça alors là il
faut carrément avoir le courage de faire
certaines choses c'est vrai que cette
fille était plus ou moins désespérée
j'ai rempli une seringue avec les
médicaments nécessaires et je lui ai dit
à la sœur ben écoutez mademoiselle
allez-y et les gens refusent toujours et
ce qui me paraît un peu horrible dans le
sens d'une loi semblable c'est que les
familles et les proches risquent de se
décharger sur un médecin d'un acte qui
n'oserait pas faire eux-mêmes qui leur
paraît à eux un meurtre alors que pour
le médecin il le baptise du beau mot
grec
d'euthanasie c'est la question que je
vouis vous poser est-ce que cette loi
vous paraît vraiment
nécessaire je crois pas franchement je
crois qu'on a déjà jamais le droit de
légiférer sur la mort ni de la sur la
condamnation à mort la loi devrait être
supprimée et au moment où cette toi
n'est pas encore supprimé en inventer
une qui permettra à trois médecins
inconnus du malade plus donc qui devront
se mettre au courant totalement de la
maladie plus deux personnes familiales
inconnu du malade aussi de décider si on
peut arrêter ou non l'existence de celui
qui est en train de vivre ça me paraît
un peu farfelu comme loi excusez-moi
vis-à-vis des juristes qui l'ont établi
mais une loi n'a de valeur que si elle
est applicable or elle ne peut être
appliquée que si elle est simple et si
la loi est simple elle m aus exactions
donc il faut qu'elle soit compliquée
mais si elle est compliquée comme
celle-là elle sera inapplicable donc le
problème me paraît presque aujourd'hui
résolu dans l'œuf cette loi ne sera pas
votée telle qu'elle et si elle n'est pas
votée telle qu'elle elle sera pas
votée avec le professeur schwartenberg
c'est un médecin donc une partie de la
médecine qui s'est exprimée ce soir une
partie seulement car en matière de
tanasie qu'elle soit active ou passive
les médecins français sont divisés comme
il l'étaient et le sont encore sur la
contraception ou bien sur l'avortement
et un exemple vient aujourd'hui nous
prouver aussi que dans le domaine de la
médecine rien n'est jamais ni définitif
ni irréversible vous vous en souvenez
sûrement il y a un peu moins de 2 ans
nous avons beaucoup parlé de Karen
quiland cette jeune américaine de 26 ans
plongé depuis 4 ans dans un Comat
profond il y a 2 ans ses parents ont
demandé et obtenu de la justice
américaine que les médecins arrêtent
tout traitement les médecins ont obéi
Karen Quillan vous la voyez est toujours
vivante elle dort sur un lit d'hôpital
elle ne se réveillera probablement
jamais alors qui peut se prononcer
l'église la médecine la
justice parce qu'il s'agit de
l'euthanasie dans laquelle la victime
elle-même va prendre la décision de
disposer
d'elle-même et le problème est
extrêmement compliqué dans la mesure où
intellectuellement on n pas le sentiment
qu'on puisse devoir refuser cette forme
d'eutthanasie et pourtant il apparaît
que dans des sociétés très
dissembla soit certaines refusant cette
forme d'euthanasie d'autres au contraire
l'acceptant et bien on a abouti à des
excès le monde médical qui se trouve
journellement confronté à des
circonstances où les patients sont ou
pensent être arrivés à la dernière
extrémité est le corps social le plus
immédiatement concerné par l'euthanasie
active ou passive et vous savez c'est
sur le tas à l'instant
même décider que on va arrêter la
perfusion qui apporte de l'eau et qui
permet de ne pas mourir de soif arrêter
le tube d'oxygène qui a apporte
l'oxygène et qui permet d'être moins
éprouvé par la difficulté
respiratoire arrêz un certain nombre de
ces éléments bien sûr qui peut-être font
souffrir et qui en tout cas sont très
pénibles pour l'entourage parce que voir
tous ces tuyau toutes ces machines c'est
certainement très pénible pour
l'entourage et aussi pour le malade je
pense décider qu'on va arrêter tout
ça c'est tout de même très c'est une
décision très
difficile chev du mourant très
fréquemment dans les pays latins un
prêtre catholique concernant les
problèmes touchants au respect de la vie
son église a une doctrine précise une
doctrine encore mal connue y compris par
les chrétiens eux-mêmes attenter à la
vie humaine sous quelque prétexte que ce
soit et sous quelque forme qu'on
l'envisage c'est monnaître l'une de ses
valeurs essentielles à notre
civilisation au plus profonde de nos
consciences chacun de nous peut
l'éprouver s'affirme comme un principe
incontestable sacré le respect à toute
vie humaine cela ne signifie pas du tout
que l'Église soit pour la prolongation à
tout prix de la vie biologique ce qu'on
appelle l'acharnement thérapeutique et
disant cela je m'appuie sur des paroles
de pape par exemple Pidou qui il y a 20
ans disait un auditoire de médecin nul
n'est tenu de recourir à des moyens
extraordinaires pour prolonger la vie
biologique Martine à larégot le dépôt de
cette loi par le sénateur cayav c'est
d'un événement un événement politique un
événement médical mais disons que pour
vous ce n'est pas réellement une
surprise c'est pas une surprise mais
c'est le début d'un grand débat de
longue durée si vous voulez mon avis en
revanche je dirais que dans nos rapports
avec la vie il y a une pièce à plusieurs
actes qui se joue qui est la rencontre
périodique du progrès de la technique
avec l'évolution de la morale et nous
sommes à l'acte de l'euthanasie passive
c'est une loi détonateure avec ses
avantages et ses inconvénients elle ne
sera pas adoptée tel quelle vous
l'imaginez bien mais elle a un mérite
énorme c'est d'obliger chacun d'entre
nous à se poser une question et à ne
plus dire je ne veux pas savoir ce qui
se passe alors l'escalade l'engrenage il
a commencé il y a 10 ans avec la
contraception puis avec l'avortement les
détracteurs ont dit que c'était le début
de cet engrenage là la stérilisation
maintenant l'euthanasie alors
l'euthanasie c'est deux deux
possibilités la passive celle qu'on
demande qui est la moins effrayante
c'est je m'abstiens de soigner je
m'abstiens de m'acharner et puis l'étape
suivante c'est active je fais ce qu'il
faut pour que tout se passe bien et je
tue pour le bien-être du malade en
question alors euh il y a un rôle
exorbitant là-dedans et schwarenberg l'a
bien montré c'est celui du médecin et
comprenez la réticence des médecins ce
sont les acteurs de ce drame les acteurs
de la mort moderne ils hésitent à la
pratiquer et puis on se pose tout de
même tout de suite une question bien
pant je montre ma volonté de vouloir
mourir dans les meilleures conditions
devenu malade est-ce que j'ai la même
impression on n est pas sûr du tout et
cela demande réflexion alors c'est
beaucoup trop court en 2 minutes de vous
donner toutes les nuances c'est tout ce
que nous pouvions dire ce soir c'est le
début d'un long débat que nous avons
l'intention de reprendre dès demain à
samedi et demi c'est-à-dire à 12h demi
Jean-Pierre elcabach et moi avons invité
un certain nombre de personnalités qui
vont venir débattre avec nous et lancer
l'opinion sur ce terrain qui est tout de
même fort intéressant nous avons le
sénateur KAV c'est lui le détonateur
deux cancérologues un réanimateur un
représentant du conseil de l'ordre des
médecins un prêtre et un malade qui
pourrait voudrait PIR choisi alors c'est
un thème aussi passionnant largement que
l'avortement et je dirais peut-être plus
bien le droit à la mort donc demain dans
samedi et demi 12h demi sur Antenne 2
les prévisions de la météo rapidement
pour le weekend demain le temps sera
encore très nuageux le matin dévoge aux
Alpes et à lacord sur le reste du pays
le temps sera variable avec quelques
averses de PLU ou de neige quelques
belles éclaircis sur l'ouest en cours
d'après-midi à 22h45 après apostrophe et
avant le cinéclub c'est Gérard qui vous
présentera ce soir le dernier journal au
nom de la rédaction d'Antenne 2 je vous
souhaite de très bien terminer cette
soirée et je vous souhaite aussi de
passer un bon weekend
bonsoir